[Music]
my name is kirsten moss i'm the dean of
admissions and financial aid at stanford
i think this is interesting today
because as i've talked to
folks who are investors within the
finance world so that's venture capital
private equity at hedge funds what we
find
about 20 of our classes from those three
industries
and about 65 of them as they're coming
in say that they will
return to investing they're interested
in that
and about the other third are often
interested in operating roles
so today on our panel you will see that
we really have a wonderful mixture about
two-thirds went back to finance and
two are now taking on more operating
roles or even an operating role within
finance more entrepreneurial roles so
you'll get a flavor of both of those
kinds of careers
so with that i'm gonna turn to our panel
and i'm gonna start
and ask each of the panelists as i
introduce them to give you a little bit
of information about their background
and then answer the question of what
their favorite
academic experience was at the gsb to
get us started
so manuel maybe you could kick us off
please
sure thanks hi everyone this is manuel
aleman from actually from colombia right
now
but i am original from el salvador i
am class of 2014 uh as you can see i'm
the oldest one
here i feel old already it's been six
years since i
left the usb it seems like less than
that
um i did my undergrad in
el salvador i stole economics after
my undergrad i went to work in
consulting for
bloggers and then in private equity i
was based
in costa rica doing privacy seeing the
central america
and andean region in south america
um i i decided that i wanted to do
something else
with my career i decided i wanted to do
something more entrepreneurial
i thought and i was correct that the
best place to do that was at the
gsb i went to the gsb and
during my time in there i was looking
for you know things to do
back in latin america related to
entrepreneurship
and specifically to consumer finance we
didn't
we didn't talk about fintech back then
but was you know i was interested in
consumer finance and serving
the underbanked population in latin
america
so after usb i joined a startup
you know it was a small start of 30
people
back then called alpha credit that
this is how to have operations in mexico
i joined
to be the general manager of something
that didn't exist
i i joined to
expand alpha credit to colombia so i
moved to colombia
and as an interesting interesting
experience
i came to colombia with two bags and one
airbnb
and worked at starbucks for the first
six months
fast forward five years we are now
in colombia a team of 300 people
we have served tens of thousands of
people in colombia
who are underbanked and our portfolio
is something more of a hundred million
dollars
in loans that we have disbursed uh to
undervalue population in colombia uh
that's us colombia and alpha trade as a
whole
we've been growing very fast both in
both countries mexico colombia we use
closed
or serious b led by softbank
and we are still expanding pretty pretty
fast
and i will be happy to talk about more
about you know the
transition from private equity to an
operational role as
as a gm of a of a country and to your
question
question of what was my favorite
experience academic experience
it was you know there's a there's a
there's a class that i i guess that is
still there
uh called acting with powers
it's amazing it's an amazing class which
for me reflects a lot about
the usb you know because the class has a
component
i would guess that something around 20
to 30 percent
there is lecture readings of
you know what power means this is
something that's really interesting
about
how you know how we as usually you know
very young people
are comfortable with power or not in
different situations
so this class was created by by
a phd in psychology who had
done some research on power he was
thought by her but it was also thought
by actors so we had actors teaching us
how to literally
act so that was so much fun because you
have the theory about
power and how do you have to behave and
what you have to do
and then we have acting classes
outside you know in in different rooms
of
how do you perform and the first classes
were just how to act so we were
act hamlet you know that was pretty fun
and then you will act with power you
know like okay so now you're the ceo
you are the gm you are the investor you
have you are you are
in a table with another company that you
want to acquire how do you
act and it was taught by actors which
was amazing so
that was one of the you know most useful
classes for me
uh i definitely have used that as you
can see you know
i still think i am young to
to be in the position that i am so
i had to use that several times in my in
my career in the last five years
and that was my favorite experience
awesome that's great thank you manuel
how about you jeff will you let us know
a little about your background and your
favorite academic experience
sure um tough act to follow given that i
don't have nearly as much
experience or um as interesting um of a
of a track but um yeah my name is jeff i
was class of 2019
um so been out for um for about a year
now
um grew up and went to school near
toronto
in canada which is where most of my
family still is
after undergrad worked at goldman for
two years
um in investment banking and then worked
at carlisle for two years in private
equity
doing consumer and retail um investing
there
um you know all along i was kind of
sitting on the
deferred acceptance program on the
stanford side so something i was looking
forward to that
you know the whole the whole time along
nothing about about my work experience
to change those plans so i started at
stanford
um and then when i graduated i came to
bain capital um
so my first year in boston um although
moving to
the new york office this this month so
um
that's kind of a quick intro on me and
then um
you know in terms of favorite academic
experience
i think there's one that stands out that
uh
you know is career related and i think
there's one that stands out that was a
little bit more
um you know tangential or you know if
not totally unrelated i think that
uh from a finance perspective
there was a class that i'd taken called
alphanomics that
you know was really about about stock
picking you know both through
um you know qualitative and quantitative
methods and for me that always felt like
a bit of a black box sitting on the
private equity side of the wall so it
was
it was great to get some insight into
that um
and then in terms of non-finance
material
um i taken a class called managing
difficult conversations
um and it was it was taught by two
professors one was actually the head of
pediatrics at
the stanford hospital and the other was
a former senior partner for mckenzie
and you know every day before class we
would read a case about
usually a health related emergency i
mean they were they were usually
these cases were usually designed in the
context of of health care but
you would be you know there in the class
of 20 or 30 people
um and two people would get called up to
role play
um you know what was always an
impossible conversation
and then um you know the professors
would weigh in on what they think
what they thought went well what they
thought didn't go well um but students
would also weigh in
on you know where where one another were
showing enough
empathy or where they could have said
things differently where they could have
done more to you know
console and provide support and things
like that um
so i think that you know i i'd be lying
if i said it wasn't the most like
uncomfortable hour and 45 minutes of my
week
every week but i think um you know it's
something i'll i'll remember
i learned a lot um and i think that um
you know unfortunately for a lot of
people you don't really get a
you don't really get a test run of those
sorts of conversations until
until you're sitting there so i feel
like you know that was something that
that stanford gave me access to it's
pretty special
okay thank you emily how about you
hi i'm emily carroll i just graduated
from the gsb
a couple of weeks ago in june um so i'm
the most recent grad here
i grew up in michigan and then graduated
from the university of michigan
i moved to new york first with bcg and
then transitioned into private equity at
a firm called helmand and friedman
i came to the gsb after three years
there
and ultimately decided to go back into
private equity
i now work for the pe firm within
the hedge fund viking global um so i can
talk a little bit about that transition
and what that was like as well
um in terms of my favorite academic
experience at stanford
um i kind of changed the answer that i
had a few times here
while you guys were talking and it's
honestly kind of hard to pick and a lot
of them are pretty fresh
for me but i would say that one that
stands out is unique
i took a class about how to pivot in
your career
that was co-taught between a woman named
allison kluger
and then alex rodriguez of the new york
yankees
so certainly a more unique experience
but we talked about a lot of things that
even though i didn't make such a drastic
career pivot i think were really helpful
for me
one was talking about what your
strengths were and just getting really
crisp about them on paper and how you
would articulate it and
where it might possibly serve you and
the class culminated in you pitching
that on
live tv um on like a local mountain view
radio or tv station that i hope didn't
have any viewers but
um was a really helpful experience for
me in terms of um being better about
advocating for myself and thinking about
what my strengths were so
it was really helpful for me that's
great
katie how about you hi guys my name is
katie hayes
i have a very similar start to my career
from what jeff shared i'm also from
toronto canada
and also started my career in investment
banking at goldman
i was in new york focused on health care
and was always really interested in the
healthcare industry which was kind of
what brought me to the us from canada
and from there i went to a firm called
madison dearborn partners in chicago
and was in private equity for two years
and then came to the gsb
and my goal at the gsb was really to
learn more about earlier stage companies
like i had worked with kind of these
bigger
fortune 500 and buyout type companies
but i really wanted to learn about
smaller companies where i thought you
know you're closer to the founder closer
to the story and it just to me
got me more excited and energized and uh
so had the opportunity obviously to do
that through
you know a lot of different courses and
internship experiences while at the gsb
um which i'll talk about um my favorite
one which was you know certainly
related to small companies and then
after the gsb i knew that i wanted to
go back into investing in some capacity
but at the smaller companies i knew i
didn't really have experience yet
like working you know really doing
anything other than
being an investor and kind of a service
provider so i worked for 18 months at a
company called open care
which is a toronto-based healthcare
startup launching a new product for them
it was by far like the most stressful
challenging role way more stressful than
investment banking um to be managing you
know sales and the p
l and budget and the team and all of
that stuff um but ultimately
joined a bc firm in toronto um a brand
new fund actually so it's kind of a
startup
and and feces fund called whittington
ventures um and i focused mostly on
healthcare investments and got to be
back in my hometown in toronto
uh and then my most um my most favorite
academic experience at the gsb was a
class called managing growing entropies
it's a pretty
um pretty popular class to take
especially for second years
um the one that i took was taught with
garcia loner who's the former dean of
the gsb
and then jim ellis who's this kind of um
awesome
you know investor um and an entrepreneur
and i would kind of describe this class
as
like the how i built this podcast but in
real life um
so each week you're kind of going
through the stories of these different
founders
um of really you know a lot of them are
very large successful companies like
bonobos and doordash
and what's really really cool about it
is it's all alumni of the gsb and often
actually alumni of that course
so multiple times the speakers actually
said oh i sat in that seat when i took
this course and i remember like this was
what stuck with me and what i brought to
my business so
it was super super cool um and
definitely recommend taking it for
for everyone who does end up coming to
the gsb
awesome and valerie
i'm valerie i was also class of 2019
with jeff and also a deferred admit
um and then i also did a joint masters
in environment and resources so
graduated in december
my background is i studied environmental
science in undergrad have always been
really interested in climate change and
clean energy and the intersection of
business and politics and science to
make that all happen
right out of college as someone who was
interested in business but didn't know
exactly what to do i went to mckinsey
for a year and a half
and then i went to kleiner perkins after
that and joined the green growth fund
which is a team investing in
sustainability in cleantech
and while i was there that fund was in
the process of spinning out and creating
g2 vp
which is a new entity investing in the
digitization of traditional industries
so i helped with the operational aspects
of setting that fund up
helped with our first investment then
came to the gsb for two and a half years
and i'm now back
at g2 vp as the chief operating officer
so what i do now is basically
run our fund as a business so everything
other than
investing decisions sort of falls under
my purview
my favorite class of the gsb so my
favorite professor
is this guy keith hennessey he was one
of president bush's top economic
advisors
and i took a bunch of his classes all of
which are awesome
the one that was most interesting was
this class called how to make economic
policy
and the whole thing was a simulation of
congress
so there was a presidential election
everyone was given a role as a member of
congress and then we had to negotiate
with each other to try and pass a bill
and it was this all-encompassing
experience where even outside of class
you were constantly trying to negotiate
to pass the bill and it really helped
you understand why it's so difficult
but love the class love keith and i'm
excited to be here with you all
awesome thank you so thank you panelists
for
introducing yourself and i'm gonna
launch onto a few questions first before
we get to those from the audience
so one of the things that we hear when i
speak with people who are in finance who
are in investing and
would like to continue when they
graduate is what's the value of an mba
why you know can i learn just as much by
staying at my firm and continuing to
work on more
more deals so jeff and emily i'll start
with you
jeff first both of you were mpe now
you've returned
if you look back what do you think the
impact of your mba
was and how did how did stanford
um contribute to that
sure so so i can take a a crack at it i
mean i think to the
initial question of you know why um you
know if you're if you're in
private equity looking to go back into
private equity or stay in private equity
why
why think about it i mean i was looking
at it a few different ways
um you know i think first at the kind of
most
macro level um you know i was just sort
of thinking about
you know first if the reason people you
know work and and make money is to
enable experiences
then you know why not why not kind of
use that time and use that money to to
enable one of the best experiences that
i could find i mean trading notes with
any alum they had basically said those
were some of the best two years that i
you know had ever had so to me that was
that was a worthwhile trade-off but then
even at the more kind of
micro career level you know for me
um i would say the two firms that i've
worked at so far
um being bain and carlisle um you know
for promotion going to business
school was still a bit of a prerequisite
for both of those
both of those guys um you know there
were very few opportunities to get
promoted
right through they preferred that folks
you know went back to business school
um acquired some new skills built a bit
of a new network
um so you know for me part of it was
just thinking that this is sort of the
the path that everybody who's done
really well my career has gone through
so i think that shaped the way i was
i was thinking about it um and then and
then lastly knowing that i had an
interest in maybe switching firms as
well
i also really got the sense that
recruiters at
firms like being in carlisle just had a
preference to hire through
a campus process to fill vp slots rather
than trying to hire through
headhunters on more of a more of an off
cycle kind of basis so i also felt like
it was the best way to
to get a few a few good looks but yeah
that's sort of the
the macro and the micro i mean i think
the macro was it was really about me and
it seemed like a great experience and a
place where i would learn a lot and have
a lot of fun but even at the more micro
level
um you know it felt like from a career
perspective it was sort of the more
trodden path
great emily yeah i think i share
a lot of your thinking jeff in terms of
why i chose to come to stanford
um the first reason i think that was
most prominent for me at the time was
i was very fortunate at that time to
have a lot of different options
and while i could have stayed and
without
having an mba necessarily and pursued
some of them i think i didn't
necessarily have enough conviction in
any one of them
um and for me just having two years to
think about what did i want
which one of those things was most
interesting to me was really valuable
i was thinking about operating goals i
was speaking about hedge funds
earlier stage investing and i could kind
of make a case for why any of them were
interesting
and having two years to really reflect
on that as well as one bullet and an
internship was really valuable to
actually try something else out
so that was the thing that was most on
my mind at the time
other things that jeff also mentioned i
think what firm fits you the best
i think you know you can bnp and you
won't want to stay in pe but that looks
really different at a bunch of different
places and
for me having the opportunity to talk to
a lot of different firms and think about
what might be a better fit for me
was really helpful um the firm that i'm
joining
for example only hires mbas so if that's
the type of
fund that's interesting to you i think
thinking about what kinds of doors it
opens in terms of credentials and just
recruiting access is really important
and then last i also just decided at the
end it was an experience i wanted to
have and
um while it added value to my life in a
bunch of different ways
one was certainly just fun and
experience and doing something different
and
i can imagine that many people coming
from finance are feeling burned out in a
number of ways and
it i think for me was a helpful reset in
terms of
what's important to me and making a lot
of life long lasting friendships i think
was a really great valuable experience
too awesome thank you emily
um you know at stanford really we
believe that our
mets have the power to change lives
change organizations change the world
that's been our motto
so i'm curious for manuel and for
valerie both of you are now in c-level
roles early in your careers
how did stanford help you achieve you
know pivot from where you were to
achieve that role
maybe we'll start with you manuel
sure it was i mean
the the way i think about it you know it
would have been
almost impossible for me at least in my
personal case
to being a role like this without having
been having gone to stanford
period so when i was
i stayed in private equity and i was
thinking that i wanted to do something
more entrepreneurial
and something with more hands-on
responsibility
i look at my options you know and i
thought well
i went to something impactful and large
and being a you know a mid-level
guy in private equity being open to me
many
doors you know in doing something large
and impactful honestly i i saw my
options and they weren't
that great or that large so
going to stanford just made a lot of
sense for me you know
when i thought what is the best place
there is to look for something
entrepreneur to do
it stand stanford was top of the list
for sure
and in my current role
what you know how i got where
where i am is that i use
meth through a stanford network a couple
of great entrepreneurs
who were based in mexico and there
wasn't
you know there was a click you know
basically
half of their investors are
from the gsb network among them gmail is
for example who was mentioned here is
one of the investors
so there was you know just this whole
network connection that
that we have in common that
for me was the key factor for which
i decided to join the startup and they
decided to give me
a very important role you know uh as
the leader of a country and as the
founder of the country
uh and that was it you know basically
the only reason why i
why i am doing what i'm doing is because
i
i went to stanford if i hadn't done that
if i would i would have gone to the same
founders as a you know
analysts from a private equity firm that
you
wouldn't have period so yeah that was my
experience
thank you ma'am well how about you
valerie how do you think about it
so i think it's been a really
interesting experience because i
actually now work with the same people
that i worked with right before the gsb
doing like work that's sort of in the
same sector of the org
but at a much more senior level so
before i came to the gsb i would really
tee up a lot of decisions for my
partners to make
and now i'm in a position where i can
actually make the decision
and just let them know what happened and
i think two aspects of the gsb really
helped with that
the first is you really just learn a ton
of best practices
and we're a pretty small venture capital
fund just 10 people
in the process of setting everything up
up so when you think about hiring and
firing the class katie mentioned manager
growing enterprises teaches you how to
practice that
um all the operational setup even best
practices on comp
and just like how you manage the org i
think i learned a lot that would have
taken much longer to learn on the job
and then the part that i think is
probably even more important
is the gsp really helps you develop a
lot of
confidence and i think it's some aspect
of you just see all these people paraded
in class as speakers who are really not
that many years older than you and you
know that they were also sort of clowns
like you a few years ago and now they
run
places and it helps you figure out that
like we too
can run the world and it makes me
confident making decisions knowing that
if i tried to tee this decision up to
someone else they're not actually more
equipped than me
um and i should just figure out what's
best based on what i see
um the gsb i think is by far to me
the most confidence building experience
and that's going to be really powerful
that's great
thank you um katie i'd like to turn this
one to you
so business school is an opportunity to
build your community of supporters
how would you describe the gsb community
and its impact
on on you yeah so
i think the gsb community is like really
just phenomenal
um i think that probably goes without
saying but i think a couple of different
ways that it impacted me that i maybe
didn't expect coming into
business school um one i always thought
about okay here's this group of
students that are in my year it's gonna
i'm gonna form friendships and then
somewhere
down the road there's gonna be this
nebulous network effect and it's gonna
be awesome and
i don't know what they're gonna do but
there's gonna be something great there
um
what i think i did not appreciate was a
that these are like just some of the
most
deep and impactful friendships that you
can have and it's so amazing because you
know i
only met these people for me four years
ago so i've you know friends that have
gone through
major life events highs lows et cetera
and i'm calling
these folks along with like people that
i've known for 20 25 years and i really
do put them like on that same level i
think
the gsb people's ability to go deep um
really quickly
and really focus on stuff beyond your
resume
or beyond your careers but more like
your goals and what makes you tick and
and you know what you're bringing into
the room
um it's really cool and i think that's
something that i've also noticed
something that i did not expect which
was
that that really translates across years
so in vc i spend a lot of time
talking to companies and getting snow
founders and like even today for example
i was talking to two different gsb
founders from years you know totally
different from mine we did not overlap
with the gsb
but that community and that shared
understanding of um
you know the maturity that people get
while they're at business school
really um really kind of resonates and i
found it in almost everyone that i've
talked to from the gsb
from i think i've got a call tomorrow
with someone from class of
67 at the gst and today i was talking to
2016. so really really a wide range
um and then the second thing i would say
is also i didn't expect to connect with
um with the professors as much as they
did we did something in my i was in a
pass down house which is like a
house um with six fellow students in
second year and we hosted these weekly
dinners with professors from a bunch of
our classes and i really
enjoyed that experience and i don't
think i appreciated how much
they genuinely wanted to get to know
students and um and really wanted to
invest in those relationships so
that was another kind of surprising
upside of the community
awesome and katie you talked about the
willingness to go deep
um was it talks small group dinners was
there any what was it for you that
really helped you
connect at that level yeah i think it
was all of the above
i think even um even just kind of the
first week at the gsb
like just getting to know people whether
it was in the residences
or walking around having lunch in like
arbuckle which is the main dining hall
you know you'd sit down with someone and
i mean maybe it's like
the weather's great every day so you
can't talk about the weather i'm
canadian that's usually like a
conversation topic
but people would just be like so what
are like you know how how are you really
doing or
stuff like that i think it was just
really all of those things um but i
definitely think that talk
uh talk was an incredible way i was
fortunate enough to do a talk um which
is a
you know kind of short um short version
of your life where you get to share
yourself to the gsb
um those certainly i think set the
precedent a little bit
um and then from there people opened up
it's awesome
that's great um jeff i'm going to pass
this one to you
so definitely true leaders understand
themselves and how to inspire
others how have you grown as a leader
from your time
at the gsb yeah so there i think there
are a few things that i've
noticed to myself and i've also gotten
you know feedback from friends and
family on having seen
progress here which i think is is great
and i attribute a lot of that to
the gsp experience i think one is just
in terms of
you know me being a little bit more
empathetic coming out of the program
than i had been
going in i mean i think the course
content gears you
toward that but also just being in an
incubator type of environment with so
many people who are so
focused on on that sort of thing and
connecting with others i think just
gets you more feedback more often and
gets you a little bit more
attuned so i think empathy is one one
thing that i think has
stood out which you know sort of impacts
um
all areas of my leadership i think the
second thing is
i think the gsp experience made me a bit
of a better
communicator uh you know taking classes
like managing difficult conversations
like i talked about
um but then also just getting me away
from writing
exclusively in bullets and communicating
exclusively through
powerpoint slides um you know i think i
think just pushed me to find ways to be
a little bit more
a little bit more thoughtful a little
bit more direct um and a little bit more
concise
um and then you know lastly i think that
i think that as as a leader and just in
general um
my stanford experience you know really
just raised the bar in terms of
self-improvement overall i mean you're
around so many driven
and amazing people you know more than
i've found
in in college or at any of the jobs that
i've worked with
for sure um and those people become your
source of influence and your source of
inspiration and i think that
um you know role models role models
um you know matter a lot and i think for
me you know classmates ended up being a
lot of those folks so i think that
you know i'm coming out of the time and
going
back into the professional world um you
know as a more
as a more capable leader at least that's
what i i hope and i don't think it's the
end of the journey i think that you know
the program has given me the the tools
that i need to continue to get
get a bit better at that awesome thank
you i'll do one last question and then
we'll take some from the audience
valerie tell us a little bit about some
extracurriculars that were
meaningful to you when you were at the
gsb
well so uh kirsten mentioned earlier i
did a ton of extracurriculars at the gsb
so i'll sort of highlight three things
that were really impactful for me
to official one unofficial so
official ones i saw someone asked about
impact investing
i was the chief investment officer of
the gsb impact fund
which was started around five years ago
by a bunch of students who thought
that it would be pretty powerful if
while at the gsb we were able to
experience
impact investing firsthand so there are
a bunch of donors who are
nice enough to give us real money that
we're able to invest every year there's
a group of now
60 students who do the whole process
from coming up with an investment
thesis to sourcing the companies doing
diligence
pitching it to an investment committee
and ultimately investing money in early
stage rounds
so it was really exciting to see that
for me it was much of a leadership
practice in that the hardest thing at
the gsb when running an extracurricular
is motivating people to actually do work
and the impact fund is 60 people trying
to convince them to stay motivated
throughout the whole process was
fascinating
the other thing i did is i planned a
number of trips travel was a huge part
of the gsb experience
the one official trip that i planned was
a global seminar to china
so it was a group of 25 incoming mba
ones
led by a couple of us to visit a number
of companies and learn about innovation
in china
and then the unofficial thing i did is
very similar to what katie mentioned
a couple of my classmates decided to
host a dinner series
uh kirsten came to one of our dinners
we've since coined that
view from the table there's a play on
view from the top
a really cool speaker series at the gsp
so view from the table gets our favorite
professors to come for dinner
and these are some of the most
fascinating conversations so i highly
recommend it
that's awesome thank you one of the
first questions we've got
that has several people asking is
is it critical for mba candidates of the
gsb interested in pursuing finance to
have a background in investment banking
and private equity
and i might so i'm gonna jump in about
this one specifically but anyone else on
the panel because i know you have
finance backgrounds who had friends who
were breaking into the industry would be
helpful to hear from you
um there are a couple of coaches that i
recently spoke to
in preparation for this panel who've
been investment and entrepreneurs as
well in the cmc and asked that same
question
for all those who are interested in
breaking into this industry because it
is hard to do
what has been our success rate what are
the issues and really the answer is
dedication dedication dedication
so it is a lot of work you may spend 20
to 30 hours just figuring out which
company you want to pitch as part of
your interviews
so their answer was literally to a
person
they were able to help students get a
job in private equity by the second year
trying to help them pivot over the
summer who were willing to put
in the effort that it really takes to do
the networking to learn to become an
expert in the space
so they certainly saw people who said
they'd like to do it and a few of them
drop out over time
but all every year all but maybe one are
able to make that pivot was what their
explanation was but anybody on the panel
see that real time with your friends who
are trying to make that pivot
one thing that i saw is the idea of like
getting into finance is really broad so
i don't have too much experience of
people trying to get into private equity
but a large percentage of my classmates
who now work in venture capital didn't
work in venture before
i think it's a much less structured
process and takes a lot of people who
are entrepreneurs or operators
so definitely there you don't need the
banking or pe experience
that's great yeah and i would i would
add that um
you know with my internship for example
i mean there were there were four
interns in my kind of intern class at
bain capital only two of them had prior
private equity experience the others
one was a consultant um and one had been
in investment banking so you know not
not um looking for prior private equity
experience in terms of breaking into
finance for people who have never done
it before
i think if you looked at the class of
2019 and
you know the folks who had gone into you
know investment banking or like
things um i think a lot of those folks
hadn't been
um hadn't been in in finance before i
think it's the
investing rules um where
you know um recruiters tend to be a
little bit more particular but i think
for like finance
writ large i think that um you know
stanford actually gives you a great
platform to
to break um to break into that
fantastic so we have a a couple mbas
matt is asking about if you want to
pivot from finance into the startup
space what skills and value does the
degree impart
upon you i don't know if any of the
panelists did startup garage and or
other things like that which would give
them the ability to become entrepreneurs
anyone want to speak to that i can speak
to it um so i guess it depends on
whether you're
looking to like found a company or just
work at a start no i shouldn't say just
work at a startup
but work at a startup and kind of be a
team member um i would say if you're
looking to
work at a startup um you're very very
well positioned at the gsb
there's just so many companies that are
looking for
um for great uh great alums and actually
frankly there's so many great gsb alums
that are like i'd love to have another
person on my team that has the shared
experience and
and can kind of help share the load
because these companies are growing so
quickly
so that you're not going to have a
problem there if you're looking to found
a company again i would say
probably similar to kristin to what you
said with the dedication piece um
with pivoting into investing there are
tons of people in my class who came in
and said yes i want to start a business
and it was the ones that really
you know potentially chose that over
traveling on spring break or did
startup garage there was basically two
semesters of startup garage so the first
one was kind of
everyone did it and then the second one
was like are you really serious about
your startup
so the people that kind of continued in
that process that i saw
that are the most successful um in
actually starting a company but un
unlike
investing you know no one has to really
you know vet your resume so the good
news is like everyone can give it a go
and i think that's that's why so many
people do really really well in the
space
awesome so kanik is asking us oh sorry
go ahead man well
i'd love to hear from you too
emily yeah sure thanks yeah
uh so sorry i have finally
it's great accent about i think
everything
okay so if you hear something in the
background
it's worked from home
so about you know about the skills that
you know i at least in my case i i got
from the from the gsb
coming from equity and getting into a
startup
world and a certain role
so i guess the usb is a amazing place
that
can actually teach you how to be a
leader you know actually being a leader
is actually
something difficult to learn and you
actually only get it from practice
but but um
bgb actually has this format in which
you can actually try conversation you
know and as
jeff mentioned uh you can actually get
to roleplay a lot
and this role plays made a difference
for me you know actually
gave me some practice on
what kind of decisions i would face and
what kind of answers i could get
getting those roles so
even though getting the skills that you
need to be an
actual leader you know you can only get
those with practice the usb was
amazing in setting in the pack
great um how about for the investors the
current investors there how
has your time at the gsb made you a
better investor
so i emily who else
would you like to kick off on that i
know you're just coming out but what
would your gut be
how about that yeah um i guess it's
unproven so i can say whatever i want
but
um i would say what i was going to say
about
your question on startup garage too i
took startup garage
including both semesters or both
quarters like you're you're serious you
continue sort of thing
um and i found it to be really valuable
and it was also just really fun
part of the stanford experience that's
unique and so entrepreneurial focused
and one thing that was cool was it just
focuses on
how can you get the best answer you can
get quickly which is very different from
what i had learned in investing which um
i
i came from environments that were very
well resourced at
h f and bcg where you would ask a
question but
you had to be fairly certain and you
would do dozens of expert calls and all
those things
and for me it was really helpful to
focus on two quarters where it was like
okay we can't do the perfect version of
this because we don't have infinite time
and resources like how can we get to a
pretty good answer fast
um and i think that more like
scrappiness approach to
problem solving was really helpful for
me to explore for a little while um
and i also learned a lot more about how
to ask better questions
and when so much of our job as investors
is how do you get to
a unique answer and maybe approach the
problem differently or ask better
questions i think
even if i can do that 10 better like
that makes me a much better investor
anybody else that might be a critical
question anyone else on the panel
have an opinion about how you become a
better investor from stanford
yeah i could um add one point which is
just that i think that
um i think that one of the things that
an mba really you know teaches you is
how to
how to find like sort of how to get
started on really any topic even if it's
not your area of expertise so you know
now
if we're doing diligence on a business
and there's like a demand planning you
know problem that involves monte carlo
analysis it's like well that's pretty
random but i did that at stanford you
know then
if we're trying to figure out like
networking capital optimization it's not
just me leaning on a consultant anymore
it's like hey i've actually
you know built models to figure out like
what safety stock should be
and what cycle stock should be from you
know the advanced operations class or
maybe you know you're trying to look at
salesforce effectiveness
um and you're trying to figure out like
whether the comp plan that they have in
place for the people in the field you
know
makes sense or or doesn't and you know
again like
um took a class on on salesforce
effectiveness at stanford so i think
it's the sort of thing where it's like
a lot of the time in an investing job
you won't really learn about some of
these things until you're in a situation
that forces you
to learn about them whereas the mba does
a great job of sort of giving you like
the surface level of almost
everything you can choose to go deeper
where you want to go deeper but it does
give you the surface level of almost
everything which just means that
when something is put in front of you
that might be unfamiliar to somebody
in your role or of your age who hadn't
done the program
um i think you're a little bit further
along the curve in terms of
knowing where to to start and sort of
like quote unquote like knowing just
enough to be dangerous or like at least
sound like you um you know are off to
the right start so i think that that's
been
that's been an area where i've found it
to be helpful i mean i've been going
back to my class notes
almost constantly and one thing i would
i would say to anybody going in is just
keep
you know keep everything on like a
online
you know box drive type of situation so
that you can
go back to those things because my
college experience was sort of like you
graduate and you can just burn it all in
the backyard like
i you know i i definitely would not do
that um here because i've been going
back
to you know this stuff all the time
awesome
uh six of our attendees would are
interested in this answer that kart
this question karthik is asking it would
be great to hear
the panelists speak about the roles the
career center professors
and the alumni network played in the
recruitment process
what was more most important and most
helpful
i would describe them all as kind of
like being on your team
and it's like when do you put them in
and you know what what position do you
put them in so i
i literally used all three i had an
awesome
advisor uh at the career center um grace
who kind of you know i told her i want
to be in toronto and
uh she was like great i don't really
have
postings but i can find you alum and
let's you know let's work through it it
was really more collaborative like she
was almost kind of like well i guess
obviously my
my coach um professors were super
helpful as well
especially given that i was specific in
my scope of introducing me to folks that
they knew in toronto both gsb alum and
just like operators that they
had you know invested in or written
cases on or knew from their network
which was super cool
and then actually the way that i found
my my first job out of the gsb
was i was at a women in management
banquet that they have every year
and was sitting with an alum and
mentioning to her she was at probably
class of
i don't know maybe five years ahead of
me and said hey you know i haven't i
haven't found anything yet but i want to
be in toronto
and she said that her roommate from the
gsb
from many years ago was from toronto and
that she would text him right now and
see if he had any ideas
he was an angel investor in open care
and so i got introduced to open care so
i think people are just like
really like if you're if you're open and
willing to ask for help and you're a
little bit specific about what it is
that you want in terms of industry or
geography
um everyone is there to help and i don't
think i could have done it without any
of those groups that you mentioned in
your in your question
awesome someone else want to take a stab
at that
yeah one thing i'd add is i just think
that because so many alum love the gsb
so much people are always eager to help
those who are still students
in part because it's like a window into
what are things like at the gsp right
now
and my example for this is i now go on a
walk in my neighborhood every day you
know like function of coveted life
um and i live sort of like pretty close
to campus right on the border with
atherton where some of the very fancy
alum live
and i walked past this this guy a couple
of times and then we realized that we
had met
at a meeting once of the gsb trust
which does a lot of investing for the
gsb and he recognized me from having
presented there for the impact fund
and then we ended up going on a walk and
then he was really helpful in thinking
through career decisions
and he just also really loved hearing
about like oh what are the kids these
days up to
um and i think my takeaway from that is
if you want to reach out to any alum no
matter how fancy they may seem
just do it and often they say yes
because they actually view it as a
mutually beneficial exchange and you
don't have to feel like a burden
that's awesome and i could i could stand
up for the cmc i guess here too
that's where i had spent most of my time
i mean you know you come back
in first year from christmas break and
you know the cmc's uploaded a bunch of
postings all over the world
you know so you know searchable by by
location
by title uh you know by specialization
kind of what have you
um i found that to be super easy to
navigate it was how
i found the job that i'm in i'm in now
and um
you know i think that there are there
are coaches at the cmc that are great
where if you want to have that
one-on-one conversation you can but
all the online tools are also super
intuitive so it's easy for people to you
know browse and try to find
try to find good fit awesome um
we have a question here about the
finance curriculum for people who don't
have finance background
it looks like from our questions there's
quite a few can you speak
to the gsp curriculum and what
you might what skills were provided and
what knowledge you might
you know need so what courses you would
take
i had a finance background but i'm happy
to also talk about it
um and there's also a question here that
says like what's one thing that got
better
over the course of covid and when
classes transitioned to being
online i think this is an area where
things have gotten better and will
continue to get better so
i was a ta for a class called corporate
financial modeling
which really starts from the basics of
like how do you build the most simple
model and it gets you all the way to
doing an lbo by the end of the quarter
in just nine weeks
um and in that class when covid hit they
doubled or tripled the size of the class
without asking the tas which was not
necessarily my favorite part
but um instead of getting 50 students on
they were able to get 150 students on
and um really provide really in-depth
learning because it transitioned really
well to a digital medium so it was
something that
there's always a ton of demand for and
there's always a long wait list so they
were able to get a lot more people into
that class
and then they also transitioned i
thought really well to digital
experience so
that professor professor dimarzo was
pretty thoughtful in terms of how he
used all the different tools and
i was really surprised by how professors
like really kind of rallied to the cause
of teaching in this way it's new for
them too
but i think they've been pretty good
about leveraging best practices across
all the classes and everything so
there's a lot of different
aspects of finance curriculum that i'll
let others speak to but i would say
i think many people will call that class
a must even if you have a finance
background i know
many people went back in and tried to
kind of fill in the holes of their tool
kit
um by taking that class and thinking
about like okay if i'm gonna
audit models that associates are
building or something maybe it's helpful
to sort of learn in this way so
that's just one data point okay
i would also just say that one of the
things that's pretty special about the
stanford curriculum relative to a lot of
business schools is just the flexibility
that it gives folks to sort of
chart their own path i mean you know you
could be somebody maybe you're somebody
who
already knows about accounting but don't
really know anything about technical
finance theory or maybe you know about
the theory if you don't know about
accounting or maybe you don't know about
you know any of it um in each of those
tracks given that you have you know the
base offering the accelerated offering
the advanced offering
you you can customize it to how much you
already know but also how much you want
to lean in
um and i think that that that's a lot
different than it is at a lot of places
where it's sort of
you know that first year curriculum
might be like the 101 suite
across the board here it's like maybe i
want to go beyond the 101 maybe you've
already done the 101 and some of these
things but not others so i think that
um you know for for me like even though
i had done an undergraduate
business program that ability to
customize
was was like one of the biggest you know
edges i think for
the stanford program but i think um
you know i think it applies to people um
i think i think it applies to anyone
really even somebody who hadn't done a
business undergrad just given that
naturally through the course of your
work experience you will have had
more exposure to certain things than
others so being able to
to customize what courses you're taking
and how advanced they are i think it's
important
great well i'm watching the time i would
love our panelists maybe to end
with um what's some advice if you could
go back
a few years and sit in the shoes of the
attendees right now
what would you want them to know either
about your experience in business school
or even
as you're thinking about you know
implying what was applying what was
helpful for you
anybody want to jump in
i can go i would use the time um that
i'm sure many of you are spending to
like reflect and
and write your essay questions you know
why you
want to come to the gsp or to do an mba
use that as like your guidepost when you
get to business school for how to spend
your time because you're going to have
like an infinite number of different
ways that you could spend
all day every day from socializing to
travel to
coursework to networking to working at
companies you know
in in the palo alto area you're not
going to be able to do all of them
um and i think uh i think if i could go
back i would definitely have kind of
used that as my north star
and try to say what's what's really
important to me um like you know like
the essay question
um and how is what i'm doing today
aligning with that
um so that you can really make the most
of the time because it is it is really
short
i have a quote up on my wall by irv
grosbeck one of our famous professors
that says
regret for what you have done can be
tempered by time regret for what you
have not done is inconsolable
and i think that's sort of the essence
of what i learned at the gsp just like
take risks go do things and i think that
applies to
like applying to school to how you're
coming up with your career
to all the decisions that you make like
just go do
things and if they fail you're gonna be
fine and if they don't fail you might be
successful beyond your wildest beliefs
oh well i think i'm going to end right
there valerie that was nicely said
our motto is to change lives change
organizations and change the world
i hope you saw a little piece of that
today thank you for joining us
and we hope i hope personally i'll have
the opportunity to read your application
soon and a big shout out to emily jeff
valerie manuel
and katie for sharing their time with us
today thank you and have a great
[Music]
evening